[Musique]
festif auto est un festival qui existe
depuis 2010 et qui se qui se passe tous
les deux ans à Rambouillet cette année
le parrain c'est Yann Arthus-Bertrand
on y voit 1500 photos qui sont répartis
dans divers lieux de Rambouillet
ce festival va se durer ce week-end à
partir de vendredi et il se terminera
donc dimanche sur trois jours et il se
déroule dans divers lieux de Rambouillet
donc la Bergerie Nationale vous y verrez
1500 photos et s'il y avait une seule
photo qu'il ne faut pas rater c'est la
photo de Tony crossetta la panthère
noire avec des yeux d'un verre éclatant
vous pourrez arpenter des lieux gratuits
mais l'entrée du festival c'est de 10
euros par personne et les familles 20
euros
[Musique]